[Musique]
c'est officiel l'office national des
forêts de la réunion change de directeur
une passation de fonction dans les
jardins de la providence
l'occasion de découvrir le nouvel homme
fort de la forêt alors il faut savoir
que le département a toujours travaillé
avec l'eau nf aujourd'hui nous avons
notre directeur régional qui s'en va
nous avons nous accueillons à nouveau et
savez que c'est important de fixer
aujourd'hui les orientations que l'eau
nf et le département vont mettre en
place pour préserver la réunion
[Musique]
donc après un premier poste d'ingénieur
en forêt traditionnelles de production
en normandie
j'ai souhaité élargir un peu le champ et
je suis parti en amérique latine pour le
compte de edf international filiale que
j'ai dirigés sur les trois dernières
années
ensuite j'ai été nommé attaché de
coopération à l'ambassade de france au
venezuela et en argentine
à mon retour lors élève m'a proposé de
coordonner la mission de croissance
externe
ensuite souhaitant retourner sur une
gestion pratique et une nouvelle gestion
directe opérationnel et retrouver les
tropiques
j'ai été nommé directeur régional de la
martinique est maintenant raconté le 1er
mars directeur régional
vernoux demande ferme le court intérim
je souhaite beaucoup de courage beaucoup
d'abnégation successeur 6 voix c'est qui
va s'éclater comme une nette hausse
il est comme ça j'ai juste après
justement cette cérémonie
je vais les rencontrer pour qu'on puisse
déjà en discuter et voir qu'est ce que
nous allons faire pour que la réunion
reste cette île préserver ce patrimoine
naturel
[Musique]
un massif forestier important avec des
enjeux en matière sociale foncier
environnementales et économiques
fondamentaux pour le développement et la
vie le bien-être des réunions
[Musique]
une forêt se gère au long terme le
forestier a l'habitude de gérer à 100 en
200 ans sur la base d'un plan
d'aménagement qui prolonge qui définit
et prolonge la stratégie la vision de la
forêt à 15 à 20 ans donc là c'est la
même chose nous nous inscrivons dans la
continuité dans une continuité à la fois
de gestion de la forêt mais également
dans une continuité de partenariat avec
l'ensemble des partenaires privilégiés
de l'office et sols des forêts à la
réunion le premier chef le conseil
départemental
ils sont passionnants parce que au-delà
de cette huile âge il ya des hommes et
yahia les institutions respectées les
hommes leur donner envie et en même
temps chacun y apporter sa touche
c'est exceptionnel après cette maison
réunion a eu cette chance d'avoir
l'office national des forêts du temps de
la colonie a eu cette chance d'avoir des
territoires qui sont maintenant gérés
par le département sous on va dire
accompagnement de l'état
donc c'est un chalenge il faut y aller
juste
[Musique]
d'accomplissement m'amuse un directeur
régional à la réunion outre atteindre
les objectifs de gestion durable et
multifonctionnelle de la forêt en
partenariat avec nos différents les
différents acteurs qui sont nos
partenaires principaux serait
d'accompagner un plus grand
développement de la filière bois locale
sur la base de la valorisation des deux
essence emblématique le cryptomérias est
le tamarin des hauts en s'appuyant bien
sûr sur note sur la filiale siège de
bonbons mais également sur un
développement d'autres produits bois
énergie et autres productions
[Musique]